Howard Stern
our you know shock jock Howard Stern
has has just made headlines for leaving
his house for the first time in two
years
first time in two years do you know why
covid
covid
this is real
I didn't believe this at first he Howard
Stern has not had not left his house for
two years
he's always been a germaphobe
and
he is just deathly neurotically afraid
of getting coveted and so finally some
of his
his celebrity friends coaxed him out
he talked about this on on his show he
said
I really had an exhausting weekend
emotionally physically for the first
time in two years I ventured out of the
house it was too much for me it was too
much
I haven't been out in two years
he said Jimmy Kimmel had been urging him
to come out he said Kimmel came over to
visit him and Stern has been demanding
that whoever visits him take covid tests
before they come into the house and the
wife Howard Stern's wife wanted to leave
but Howard said no no
he said I said to my wife before this
dinner I don't want to go I'm in a panic
I don't want to get coveted
he said effort I know I'm being a wuss I
know I'm cleaning up the language a
little but for me covet is still going
on and I haven't left my house I can't
figure out how to integrate myself I've
been locked up so long and I haven't
gotten coveted I'm afraid I'll be the
one a-hole who gets coveted and I'll die
even though people don't seem to be
dying that much anymore he's still so
afraid I know I know people like this
I have friends and relatives who who
still
really don't eat inside restaurants
they'll try to eat outside even if it's
blistering hot even if it's freezing
cold they just don't they're just too
they're so neurotically afraid of covid
and it's the same thing it's the same
impulse
Howard Stern is is experiencing that the
Millennials who want to buy the adult
Happy Meal are experiencing
it's just
the refusal to accept
life as it is that you're born
and you live
and you die
and time moves on and we live in time
and space and you don't get to freeze
Time Forever
and circumstances change
people get sick
and time moves on and you've got to make
good use of your time
think about Howard Stern oh my gosh he's
lost two years of his life
two years of it let's say Howard Stern
lives to 90 years old
he'll he'll really have lived for 88
years right those two years he's been
hunkered down like a complete maniac
and I think about this with the
overgrown children Millennials who still
want to you know who are still shocked
when they if they pay their own cell
phone plan which is uh infrequent
because a lot of them are on their
family cell phone plans but if they pay
their own bills every now and again
they'll say I'm adulting I'm adulting as
though they deserve a cookie for for
doing things that that 30 year olds are
expected to do no and you just think
about okay they live to be 90 years old
but emotionally they're still 16. that's
sad they've missed a lot of their life
yeah they've missed the hard parts and
the suffering and the prospect of
sickness and the the risk of death even
they've missed those things because
they've been so coddled and they've been
so so uh cautious and they've been so
afraid to actually live but they miss
life too that's what they've also missed
that's not good we need to we need to
return to some semblance of normal
okay we need to we need to recognize
sickness happens suffering happens it's
okay responsibilities happen you're not
going to get to sleep as much when you
get married and have kids you're not you
have to work a little harder you're
gonna have to make a little bit more
money okay that's fine you're going to
die someday that's true that's the way
it is just don't why would you live in
constant fear of that if you live this
is a trick of the devil but if the if
you live constantly harping on the past
whether out of anxiety or out of
nostalgia
and or if you live on the future and
trying to protect that future so you
never get sick and you never die or
anything you completely miss the present
which is the only place where you can
actually live you only live in the
present
so either way you spend all your life in
the thinking about the past daydreaming
or daydreaming about the future you're
not living in the present
grow up not you you know what you're
doing but these crazy people out there
they got to grow up
speaking of returning to normal I
mentioned yesterday that Elon Musk is
looks like he's going to actually be
buying Twitter
what that means is
the the only thing that forget about we
can voice our views we conservatives
finally have a shot forget about our
follower counts forget
it means that Trump can return
Elon Musk has already said he said I
think Banning Trump was a mistake
because it alienated a large part of the
country and did not ultimately result in
Donald Trump not having a voice he said
the decision was morally bad so it's not
just that it was tactically sort of bad
he said it's morally bad
and he says that he would reverse the
permanent ban
now this is complicated because Trump
has said that even if the ban is lifted
he won't go back to Twitter
he'll remain on his own platform which
is truth social and presumably when he
signed on to truth social it included
some Provisions in the contract that say
he can't go back to Twitter or something
right because that would that would
really gut truth social and Trump
doesn't want to do that
so what's he going to do he's in a
really tough position right now
this is one of the toughest political
positions Trump is in
the the only one that's tougher is the
covid vaccines
because Donald Trump did allow fauci to
have more of a platform Trump did not
reopen the country after Easter as he
had sort of dangled out there that he
could which I think would have been
amazing he did
get us the vaccines which he's gotten a
lot of credit for but the vaccines have
a lot of problems and then there were
vaccine mandates not because of Trump
trump didn't want to mandate them but
then the mandates came in later and so
Trump is in this tough position where a
lot of his base myself included hates
the lockdowns and doesn't like the
vaccines and
he was one of the Defenders of the
vaccine so albeit not the Mandate so
that's it's just that's a tricky one for
him to navigate and then this one is
tricky for him to navigate
because
if he refuses to get back on Twitter
it looks like he's just privileging his
private business interests over his
political life
or it could look that way and he would
be limiting his reach because people
just don't use truth social the only
reason people use truth social is to see
what Trump is saying and then they share
it to other social media platforms
so I I read a bunch of Truth social
posts but I read it I just really read
what Trump writes because I'm just
interested in what he has to say so
that's what happens if he just stays
untruth social but if he goes over to
Twitter one it guts true social right so
this company just goes away and
two
it might be seen as though he's going
back and playing by their rules he said
he wouldn't do it and then he did it
anyway now where do I come down on this
I want him to have his Twitter again he
should they don't want him to have
Twitter
he will have a much broader reach if
he's on Twitter I want him to go back on
Twitter I think it is likely to help him
and his prospects in 2024 which are
still very very strong he's atop the
Heap by a long shot but especially in
Florida DeSantis now has a lead over
Trump in a prospective 2024 presidential
race I think in the middle of the
country Trump is still just so much
stronger and better known than DeSantis
is DeSantis just hasn't been around that
long obviously he doesn't have the name
recognition that go goes along with
being a celebrity for 40 years and the
president for one term
but still if you're a trump you got to
be a little worried about that and so
and then the most important reason I
think Trump should go back on Twitter I
would find it very entertaining I would
love that I would love it I would get to
retweet it a lot and so I strongly
encourage him to do that okay the rest
of the show is continuing now you do not
want to miss it we've got fake headlines
we've got the real headlines from the
week there's one fake headline in there
the producers have sent these to me you
have to guess and then I have to guess
which the fake headline is I've been on
a roll so far we will see how it is
going over at the member block see you
there
[Music]
foreign
[Music]